this morning we are learning more about
the u.s raid in syria that ended with
the death of one of the world's most
wanted terrorists
the isis leaders we told you yesterday
exploded a bomb that killed himself and
members of his own family as american
special operation forces closed in
president biden praised u.s troops for
the raid who returned to the base
without suffering any casualties nancy
cordes reports from the white house
they found al qarashi he was known as a
hands-on leader who took over isis in
2019
last night's operation
took a major terrorist leader off the
battlefield and has sent a strong
message to terrorists around the world
we will come after you and find you al
qarashi was blamed for orchestrating
massacres and rapes of iraq's yazidi
people
and for directing recent attempts to
free at least 3 thousand isis fighters
from a syrian prison
isis may not be as strong as it once was
but cells are still capable of carrying
out deadly attacks like the suicide
bombing at kabul airport last summer
that killed 13 u.s service members and
nearly 200 afghans
u.s commandos went in this time by
helicopter backed up by armed drones and
fighter jets pentagon officials say the
45-year-old blew himself up killing his
wife and two children as u.s special
forces surrounded his home in
northwestern syria one helicopter broke
down and had to be destroyed and left
behind this is a man that we should all
be happy is no longer walking on the
face of the earth for cbs morning's
nancy cordes at the white house